they show how it was and they show how
it should not be and there also if you
look at what we've been doing with the
automatic exchange of tax information
and the transparency issue and the
questions the base erosion and profit
shifting what you will see is that we
made a lot progress since the crisis we
made more progress than the last 50 or
60 years now already we have 85 billion
euros that have come into the coffers of
the Treasuries by people who come and
say well in the hypothetical case of a
hypothetical individual who have created
a hypothetical account you know what
would you do now this is because they
know it's inevitable it's coming if we
actually started with automatic exchange
of information in September last with 50
countries another 50 countries will come
next September so we're basically
talking when you talk about Panama
papers paradise' papers about how it
used to be you're talking about legacy
and you're talking about a past that in
a way is coming back to haunt us but
that is in the verge being dismantled by
virtue of this work that we have done
collectively what about the British
governments in particular is it doing
enough to ensure transparency from its
overseas territories it's always
fascinating because I every everybody
knows and they all trust that the UK is
working with us very closely and they
are of course they're very enthusiastic
very supportive but they also said and
David Cameron said I will deliver you
know and George was one then and then
after that Philip Hammond and Theresa
May had said we will deliver the Crown
Dependencies and they have the isle of
man and Guernsey and Jersey etc and that
also gives us a lot of you know moral
authority gives the UK moral authority
to demand that other countries do the
same do you wonder as we get nearer to
the moment when Britain leaves the EU
we're going to be entering a greater
period of international tax competition
tax competition is something which is
not very well understood by the general
audience it basically suggests that by
lowering your tax rates you would
attract investment but I don't think
that people understand why a company
makes a decision to install itself in a
particular country nobody would be in
the European the theater of production
nobody would be in the UK nobody in the
United States if it were only because of
the taxes it's about productivity it's
about the skills it's about the
financial centers it's about you know
the the business climate in the business
rules and the regulations so it's not
just about taxation taxation of course
the more competitive you are it's okay
but it doesn't mean that there has to be
a race to the bottom here